welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
dana white's contender series returned
last night for the 50th rendition of the
popular show white awarded contracts to
all five winners three of which came via
knockout at the post fight press
conference white was asked what he
thought about paddy pimlet's weight
fluctuation between fights white
expressed that while he doesn't think
it's a good idea he won't be getting in
the middle of it it's not good for you
you know i mean we all know that we know
that fluctuating and cutting that much
weight is is very bad
and um
and it
definitely doesn't prolong your career
you know it's it's tough on your body
and and your organs and stuff like that
but listen he's a grown man he can he
can do whatever the hell he wants to do
um you know it makes it tough for us too
because
when we're in the matchmaking room we
want to throw together a fight maybe
maybe we could throw him on a card in a
month month and a half it hurts us too
we have to be very specific when we plan
fights for him because he's not he's
nowhere near close to weight and what
you don't want to do is put that kind of
pressure on him to cut that much weight
in that short amount of time so after
the events of ufc san diego white might
not need to put that much thought into
pimblet's next fight bobby green a
fighter guest at the event secretly
filmed pimblett who was also in
attendance while simultaneously talking
trash green urged his followers to tag
pimplet in the video who was well out of
your shot
i just have to say it look at this
[Applause]
look at this little fat head right here
at this little fat head
a little fat hair guy right there
who is this fat head guy
can somebody tell me who this fat head
guy is
no me and jamal healing beef no more
who is this fat head right here
who is this guy
i want to know
who is this guy right here
who is this guy right here
they said he's the baddie i don't know
about the daddy
if he's bad he'd fight me
if he was bad
if he was bad
you know if you really want to fight
somebody real
somebody with some real credibility
not this monkey king
bro
the real ones
[Laughter]
man so y'all can tell him let him know
what i'm saying let him know is he gonna
i don't want to disrespect him in front
of this girl he's with his little lady
friend right now
and i'd be just i'll just be mean
things are heating up between aljamain
sterling and tj dillashaw ahead of their
banted weight championship bout at ufc
280. on a recent episode of the mma hour
sterling stated that he doesn't think
dilishaw is a clean athlete a callback
to dillashaw's two-year suspension for
using performance-enhancing drugs
dillashaw responded to those remarks
from sterling in an interview with mma
junkie he's got to say something to
downplay how good i am i'm going to
whoop his coming up soon in 10 weeks
he's got to make some sort of excuse of
why i'm winning or who i am and why i am
it don't bother me it's just a bunch of
excuses when i beat his he's going to be
like see dillashaw also spoke about the
advantages he has over sterling and how
he sees the fight going i absolutely
have the advantage in striking i believe
i have the advantage everywhere he's
really good once he gets on the back
with control and things like that i
haven't been impressed with his
wrestling he's a d3 wrestler and i've
been wrestling d1 i think his takedown
defense is under 50
his striking is it's embarrassing that
he's the champion his striking that is
that bad it's god he uses his
awkwardness to his advantage but when
you start throwing with him he just
cowers i don't know there's a lot there
i can out-grapple you i can out-strike
you i'm going to put on a clinic in
bare-knuckle fighting championship news
former ufc fighter paige van zandt is no
longer fighting on this weekend's card
in london the news is broken on twitter
by mma news in a single tweet confirmed
paige van zant will not be fighting this
weekend fight against charissa segala is
moved to october 15th still uncertain
that's the reason initial report talked
about ticket sales but now hearing
issues from paige's side van zandt
however walked back on the claims that
the fight fell through because of issues
on her end in a tweet of her own vanzant
shared her side of the story this is out
of my control i went an entire camp and
weight cut to be pulled a week out i did
not pull for my fight i was pulled i am
pissed off and heartbroken i worked my
off to be pulled a week before i am
supposed to compete
on episode 280 of the weighing in
podcast with josh thompson and big john
mccarthy the duo discussed the recent
criticism dana white's contender series
fighter bo nichol has received nickel
has been on the receiving end of doubt
recently notably from anthony smith and
luke rockhold thompson and mccarthy
defend the nickel saying he is in fact a
legit prospect and that by the time he's
ready to make his mark in the ufc his
doubters will be long or tired ball
nickel is the real deal bow nickel is a
phenomenal wrestler out of penn state
and he has been
working as a fighter for the last
several years
look american top team dan lambert
opened up an att
at penn state right outside of it
because of bone nickel
all right the the guy is gonna be
something dana knows he's gonna be
something this whole thing with oh dana
didn't sign him from the dana white
contenders thing
stop okay dana's already
taken care of that they know that all
he's trying to do is get in more fights
before he gets into the ufc the guy can
wrestle his ass off and
will wrestle most guys ass off in the
cage
and he can also hit submissions he can
also you know smack people around he's
good
but
to put him in the position of
right now that um
he can be is he
he's not
in any fashion in the mma world
has he experienced the things that he
needs to experience
to take on someone like izzy at this
point beau nicholl good bow nickel is
good is he you know the second coming of
christ no
but he's a he's going to be a great
fighter no doubt about it and and the
ufc is
they've already got him signed i think
um
i think it's brilliant what dana's doing
he understands what kind of talent he is
he understands how marketable he is
um it's not very often you get a
a talented
good good wrestler who can talk on the
mic
and has already started working towards
his progressions
of um submissions and wrestling together
and as a ginger i mean let's be real i
can market a ginger it's the easiest
thing i can do it's not like he's not
going to be recognizable walking through
the crowds
and what i love about him honestly
there's no hate he is people these
fighters got to stop hating on him he's
got three fights leave the freaking guy
alone even more by luke man luke i love
you we shouldn't even have this
conversation
let the kid enjoy his moment these
moments
on the dana white contender series he
will be he will eventually get towards
the top
but you will be long gone luke same with
some of these other guys izzy might even
be long gone by the time he gets there
is he might that's how that's how long
it's gonna take this kid to get there
looking for more original mma content
watch the latest episode of fight night
flashbacks on thick boy youtube brendan
schaub and eric griffin look at the rise
of kamara usman ahead of his title bout
with leon edwards this weekend at ufc
278
you